what's your take on the
version of feminism that exists today
not the one that
i mean like you and i are pretty close
to the same age i'm like the version
that i remember growing up was
you know
let's just you know try to make sure
that women have an equal opportunity you
know sort of thing right um yeah today
it
from my perspective
it appears to be more of a supremacy
movement where
it's not so much concerned about making
women better it seems more concerned
about taking men down or making them
less
and uh not doing anything to improve the
state of women it removes femininity
from the equation is pretty much the way
that i would look at it like what's your
take on the way that feminism looks like
today
i i agree with what you just said um
what i what i see is
is that there is a movement and a
growing trend
would and this is ironic because this
feminist type movement that we see today
will undermine and mock and dismiss and
ridicule masculinity and in the very
next breath they'll tell women
not directly but this is their messaging
is that you have to act like a man in
order to be equal or better than a man
so it's like well which is it
is masculinity and manliness harmful and
destructive and bad or is it that
you should act more like a man so that
you can be his equal
and i don't think a woman acting like a
man makes her equal
to to a man and makes her an inferior
version of a woman like that that's the
only outcome of it so when i you know
when i look at women you know my wife is
a great example of this she's a
stay-at-home mother she's a homemaker i
just did a podcast with her
uh earlier we were on somebody else's
podcast and the gentleman said how would
you like me to introduce you and she
said
uh wife and mother
that's that's right because that that
has her that's her greatest calling
she's wanted to do that and be that from
the time that she was little but the
feminist movement we see today would
laugh and scoff at that oh oh you're
you're gonna be inferior oh your husband
under your thumb or you're under your
husband's thumb i can't believe he's
keeping you barefoot and pregnant and
she's over here thinking i'm just living
my best life i'm here i'm supporting i'm
nurturing i'm guiding i'm counseling
with him i'm turning this house into a
home and so i have a real issue with
women's empowerment
when it's not really about women's
empowerment it's about turning women
into inferior versions of men
yeah it's it's so bizarre because it's
like the like the version of feminism
today seems to tell women that
you can't do anything for the express
pleasure of your man make him a sandwich
bring him breakfast uh
you know bring him a a nice glass of
iced tea while he's working outside
doing something you know for the you
know for the household but they'll
encourage them to go and uh you know get
a job get a degree frame it in mahogany
with little letters after their name and
go and serve a boss who's probably you
know more likely than not a man like
that's that's good serving your
household is bad
right right it's such a bizarre story
it's interesting
i come home from jiu jitsu uh two to
three nights a week
and when i get home
food's on the counter
you know and i say what you know what
what did we have for dinner tonight
she's like yeah we had you know steak
and potatoes and broccoli awesome uh i'm
gonna go take a shower she's like great
i'll warm up your food for you
and i come down and the food's warm and
it's sitting there and it's beautiful
and it's delicious and i eat it and i
honor her and she honors me that doesn't
make her inferior she wants
she's expressing her love and admiration
for me like this is a partnership she's
expressing her gratitude
that doesn't make her like subservient
or a slave or servant to me it's just
this is the way that she's expressing
her gratitude and appreciation for the
relationship that we have it does make
her an outlier today though i mean the
values
especially in urban centers believe that
that's not the goal anymore the goal is
to compete with men climb the corporate
ladder get degrees and then by the time
they're like
40 and they've got two eggs left over
they rush out to go out and try to get
married and have a family right yeah
that's that's what they you know usually
end up with they come to an epiphany at
some point in their late 30s or even
early 40s where they're like
i'm screwed i made some bad choices and
this isn't really what i wanted right
and they're surrounded by a few cats and
a box wine subscription and a
boss that they hate and a patriarchy
that they uh you know march against
right
yeah
uh well it is it's a shame that they're
being fed that line that's the real
issue is that they're being fed that
line angry bitter women who did the same
thing and they want other people to do
follow in their footsteps so they too
can be miserable
it feels like a losing battle today
though like what's your take on that
because i mean i i'm i'm kind of at the
point now where it's where it's like i'm
just
just leave me alone don't tax me stay
out of my life i'll just enjoy the
decline as things sort of unfold as time
passes on right but um
you know there's there's others that uh
haven't haven't gotten there or may not
get there or may get there at some point
like i'm just curious uh about your take
on that that role that society plays
today because
like the way that you live and the way
that you describe coming home from the
dojo and dinner's ready and you can take
a shower and she'll heat it up and
there's none of this like i remember um
you know a buddy of mine telling me once
you know um you know recently married
had a small child that was about six or
seven months old and he came home from
work one day and he's like
you know uh hey sweetheart you know
what's for dinner and uh she scoffed at
him went to the freezer took a bag of
some frozen stuff with another and
whipped it at him and he was like yeah
yeah he's like what is this like what is
i didn't sign up for this
yeah i mean that's a bitter that's a
bitter move right like there's a lot of
bitterness and contention in doing
something like that now granted like i'm
not gonna disrespect my wife by saying
woman go make me a sandwich because
that's what you know some guy that's not
what i do i'm not saying that at all
like there's a balancing act here like
i've got to respect her too and the more
i respect her the more she's going to
respect me in return and we're going to
serve each other
um
so
with with your your question about uh
the balance between you know disengaging
and being engaged it's it's interesting
man i just i said i moved to maine uh we
bought 50 acres out here we live in a
very rural area
i too want to be left alone i don't i
don't want you to bother me
um i want to live my life i want to
raise my kids uh i don't i don't want to
get into stuff that doesn't make sense
to me or i think is destructive
i want to make a little money have some
experiences like i want all of that and
more
but i don't think that i get to absolve
myself of what's going on in society so
one of the things that you said was pay
less taxes or or just pay my taxes or
not pay more taxes well if we don't get
involved like you're going to pay more
taxes
like that's the inevitable outcome is
that there is no there is no universe in
which we'll be left alone it's a
constant march against
the way of life that we enjoy in the way
of life that we want to have and so is
it a losing battle
yeah man probably in a lot of ways until
it gets so bad that enough people wake
up i i think probably it is
but the result or or
the the the opposite is to do nothing
and just to let it happen quicker
and i can't do that i what i want to do
is i want to rally men
around the concepts that we're sharing
and empower and embolden them to live a
life of meaning and significance so that
we can ward off some of this nonsense
before it gets too bad hey guys i really
hope that you enjoyed that short clip if
you did consider supporting the creation
of content by checking out my supplement
line pinned in the top comment below of
this video in the comments there's a
link to the unpluggedalpha.com forward
slash shop when you click through you'll
be able to land over here and the entire
lineup is broken down by category that
it performs best in estrogen metabolism
fat burning your foundational essentials
for health immune health performance and
testosterone support if you check out
with coupon code alpha 10 you'll get 10
off on your first order there's also the
option to use the subscribe and save
model or regular shipments will be sent
over to you on a regular basis and that
gives you a little bit of a discount and
your supplement facts are always broken
down over here thanks for watching i
hope you guys have an awesome day and
again check out that link it's pinned in
the top comment below in this video
peace out
you